entre estas cuatro paredes fue
encontrado una misteriosa reserva de
vacunas no menos de 29 millones de dosis
descubiertas en este subcontratista de
astrazéneca fueron halladas por la
policía italiana que especie no la
fabrica a petición de la unión europea
lo que refuerza aún más la desconfianza
de bruselas hacia el laboratorio sueco
británico ya sospechoso de favorecer a
reino unido vemos que los compromisos se
mantienen casi en su totalidad con
ciertos países en particular con reino
unido y no con la unión europea lo que
es una situación totalmente inaceptable
la unión europea no será el blanco de la
broma de la vacunación exige a quien
estaban destinadas estas vacunas las
oculto astrazéneca deliberadamente el
laboratorio no responde en un comunicado
astrazéneca afirma que no está previsto
exportar las fuera de la unión europea
salvo a países empobrecidos a través del
mecanismo internacional kóvacs
actualmente no está prevista ninguna
exportación fuera de los países del
programa kóvacs hay 13 millones de dosis
de vacunas en espera de la validación
del control de calidad para su envío a
kóvacs
según el presidente del consejo italiano
se han incautado algunos lotes de las
vacunas descubiertas cerca de roma y se
han enviado dos lotes a bélgica
este episodio alimenta un poco más la
disputa entre astrazéneca y la unión
europea- el laboratorio ya había
revisado a la baja el número de vacunas
que se enviarían al bloque comunitario a
finales de junio 100 millones de dosis
frente a los 300 millones previstos en
el contrato celebrado con bruselas